Let's have a little bit
more fun with operators.
We'll start by using just
literals to demonstrate but
these operators work with variables,
constants and if you're accessing struct
property values like we've seen so far.
First, let's add two numbers together.
And as you expect, 5 + 3 is 8.
We can subtract two numbers.
And notice if we use subtraction
between these two numbers,
5 and 2.5, where one is a floating point
number, we get a floating point result.
And that's because the Swift compiler
is smart enough to know the difference
between subtracting two integers here
and getting an integer result and
subtracting out a floating point value
here to compute a floating point result.
We'll go ahead and do the same for
multiplication and division.
But here's something that's
a little bit interesting.
How come when we divide 5 by
3 we just get the value of 1?
Well, since the Swift compiler
knows both of these literal values
are integers.
When it performs the division,
it does not include the decimal part.
Instead it truncates
the decimal part and
leaves you with this whole value of 1.
Now let's see what happens with
the dreaded divide by 0 case.
It looks like the Swift compiler's smart
enough to know that this is a divide by
0 and it can't execute this,
but enough with these literals.
Let's try some actual variables now.
I've created these ahead of time so
I'm just going to paste them in.
And we have a variable for
the value 5, 3 and 0.
And now we're trying to do
the same 5 divided by 0 or
a divide by 0 case but,
what's going on this time?
Last time the Swift compiler was
able to detect the divide by 0.
Well this time since
we're using a variable,
the Swift compiler cannot
automatically detect the issue.
Instead, the playground file tries
to run this code and as you can see,
the execution's interrupt
because it can't execute this.
And we can tell that the execution of
the playground stopped because if I try
to go a line below and
do anything, we can see that it never
reaches this line, it stops right here.
So let's just remove this and
comment this line out.
There's one more operator I want to
introduce which belongs with add,
subtract, multiply and divide and
that's the remainder operator,
also called the modulus operator.
Many times you'll hear it called mod for
short.
The mod operator allows us
to perform division and
then return only the remainder and
this operator's
really useful when determining
multiples or if a number's even or odd.
By the way, the modulus operator is the
percent sign and we can see if we mod
10 by the number 2, the remainder is 0
so we know that 10's an even number.
Let's try this with an odd number.
And in this case, because the result
is 1, we know that the number's odd.
But you don't just have to do even and
odd.
Let's try an example for,
say, multiples of 5.
We know that 5 is a multiple of five but
6, 7 and 8 are not and
we can see the remainders here.